so crazy so you meet a girl for the
first time like what's your name nice to
meet you
how much how many guys you slept no no
if we're dating and then we're
things are getting more and more serious
then i would ask but
if you don't i guess i would put it
another way right let's say the girl is
ticking all the boxes for you
not perfect but a lot of the boxes
and you have a
like you have a suspicion and you don't
want to ruin it maybe remain ignorant
maybe if you don't want to ruin it for
yourself and everything else is great
then maybe you're an ignorant but i
think what pearl said is really
true because
sometimes their friends will come out
you know
a mate of a mate will know her can i say
something like i feel like you start
dating someone
because the way you put it down is more
like tell me everything of everything
about you already it's a bit too much to
chill so obviously if you study you know
you ask her you know i kind of hear that
you've been with this guy this guy
sure maybe the girl would say yes and
then from that on like she said the
truth eventually will come out yes but
it normally wouldn't be your business i
would say it goes with me in the past
personally i am today and
guys shouldn't judge in any way girls
have been quite honest with me in the
past like they've been open with me
they've opened that conversation quite a
few times more than i have
so if they open that conversation with
me then i at least give them the benefit
of the doubt and say like
are you trying to pull the wall over my
eyes and sometimes it's been
more than i'd like
but then i've i've thought
there's
there's good things here yeah and i
think no like it goes back to the high
value man thing right it depends on how
much leverage you have in life how many
options do you really have
because if you want i guess it comes
down to this if you want uh to be with
someone
marriage kids whatever if you want to be
with someone
there are compromises you're gonna have
to make so if you don't have many other
options on the table and she brings a
lot to the table
then
give her a shot
so i have a question for you so
um
when they take a girl that's a virgin
they come back to her in 10 years and
ask if she's happily married if she's a
virgin she has an 80 chance of a happy
marriage if she slept with more than
five people it drops to
30 percent
knowing that information don't you think
men should judge
because wouldn't you rather take the
girl that's an 80 chance versus a 30.
wouldn't that be a better bet that's
inside the church no that's not that's
just women that's the so they surveyed
women they said how many people did you
sleep with then in 10 and 10 years they
came back to see if they were happily
married the virgin 80 chance they were
happily married um
outside of that 30 chance
yeah of course but that's
that's facts because of course if i'm
ignorant and i never like known sex i
was also
mm-hmm but maybe can you do someone you
you know you get to know your sexuality
can i just get a yes or no would you say
they should judge that knowing that
information because you said before they
shouldn't judge but now that you know
information that virgins are better the
less people you sleep with is better
would you say men have a right to judge
because they want better outcomes no one
is allowed to charge anyone to be honest
person that's why i believe no one is
like okay
maybe
maybe maybe let's not say judge let's
say be
discriminated be picky with who they
date and not date the hoes they will
rather obviously of course going with
someone that's more conservative virgin
so he's like yeah well perfect but their
happiness and the marriage will come
from ignorance as soon as you start
learning your sexuality then you decide
what you want to do with it but
personally i feel like no one should
judge anyway because the guys are known
they're no angels they're not saying i
understand what you're pointing i'll see
what you mean though because obviously
you get i'm not expectations the more
people use it maybe got more maybe
expectation and also um
i feel like a lot of relationship is
something that should add onto your life
not something that you need or you're
looking for that's why maybe so many
girls are like oh my god i can't find it
because you're looking for it too much
it's desperate for it so that's why
maybe
maybe maybe judge isn't the right word
but you do agree they can be selective
and not date the girls that have slept
around like you think that's fine
yeah i mean of course why is it why is
it a problem to be like ignorant of
of how other men are sexually
like i'm looking forward to to being
with my future husband i've never had
sex but i'm looking i'm looking forward
to just being with him and i don't want
to be with anyone else but sure why is
it bad that i'm going to be ignorant of
how other men are it's kind of like
objectifying them no it's not bad it's
fact because if i um they say i've never
had sex before and now i'm getting
married i don't have sex
just after i was gonna have sex when i
get married right
now you don't know sex you're getting to
learn sex with your husband
now if you only have one person
throughout your whole life of course
there's more chances of you being happy
you don't know nothing else no maybe
you're gonna cheat one day and these
guys bell so what are you gonna do
because i watch no because in in my eyes
he's the best i'll ever have
like i i won't i don't have anyone to
compare him to so why why is it a
problem i'm gonna be happy either way
well
i've been cheered on and i'm perfect
no i'm joking i'm joking guys but i'll
see you i see your point of view but
i don't know life is strange it can be
many situations where
maybe they because women will cheat more
because of the mental connections more
than the physical guys would go for like
i'm feeling that maybe my wife's tonight
she got she got a headache she's not
gonna be sleep she's not gonna sleep
with me now a guy will go and cheat a
woman needs more like maybe their mental
connections more to cheat i think i
thought
personally but
you never know in life maybe you're
going to know someone that's better than
your husband no you said no
i wasn't shaking my head at that i was
shaking of the head of like a girl not
having sex with you like if i'm making a
guy wait until marriage like i'm gonna
have sex with him whenever he wants no i
don't i don't think that's that's not
the point like if you want to wait it's
you have all the rights to wait and you
should find someone who's willing to
wait for you shouldn't be like make you
feel guilty for you to not wanting to
have your sex
but obviously if you if you guys saying
oh if um girl is a virgin and then 10
year later then happily marriage of
course because sex is
you know is a big values of it so of
course if i'm having a lot of options
but but you don't know nothing because
you're like you're virgin right for
example there's more chance he's going
to be happy there like that's what my
point i don't know if that game yeah so
that's like preferable like the men
should go for the virgins if they can
yeah of course yeah they will but they
have this uh superman type of like ego
that they should like kind of like sit
down and
i would say
i would say that most men don't have a
super um super ego i'd say most women
are pretty narcissistic because most
women think that they're
um and just things like that like um i'm
special like most women think they're
special i think that's social media as
well yeah increase that a lot because
now you see girl people that just
don't know i think they like beyonce
you're like
loads of guys are going to swipe on you
you
you don't know what you don't know you
might value that you look at that it's
like that little dopamine here oh i've
got 10 matches today you don't even want
to speak to any of them
but it makes you feel good it makes you
feel like more than you are you know
um that was actually
my next oh wait i think some people
didn't actually answer the dating app
question
so what as a guy what has your
experience spent on dating apps so
sitting behind the camera off camera is
my girlfriend we met on a dating app but
there is a bit more to the story so
obviously girls don't set their radius
very big because they don't need to
she uh lived outside of london we went
to the same comedy gig in london hodge
twins gig if anyone knows the hodgepodge
oh my god they're in london yeah
a while ago i don't know if they'll come
back hopefully they will
um
and so we matched through that as many
of you know i was just banned on tick
tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible